We'll talk
about historic verdict on a char
rarely brought to trial in the U
The leader of the Oath
Keepers, Stuart
Rhodes, has been found guilty
by a Washington DC jury
of seditious conspiracy for his
in the January six attack
on the US Capitol.
Rhodes was also
one of the five Oath Keepers
Oath Keeper
defendants to be convicted of ob
an official proceeding
which on its own
could carry a 20 year prison sen
Prosecutors argue that Rhodes
stood outside the Capitol on Jan
acting like a general
as his followers breached the bu
So joining us now, Tayshia Adams
She is Tewodros ex-wife
who helped him
start the Oath Keepers
more than a decade ago.
She has since left the group
and has condemned Rhodes
and the Oath Keepers
for their involvement on January
This is her first interview, by
The first TV interview,
I should say, since the verdict
Thank you so much for joining us
We really appreciate you
joining us this morning.
How are you doing, Tasha? Oh,
yeah.
Amazing.
The best I've done in a long tim
What's your reaction to your ex-
being convicted on these days,
especially the historic one,
a seditious conspiracy?
Well, that was the big one.
That's the one
I was really worried about.
I was so relieved.
I don't even know how to put int
the difference between
the way the world feels now
and the way the world felt to me
before yesterday.
3 p.m. my time.
Except to describe it
as like being in a really noisy
for days, weeks, months on end.
And then it just suddenly quiet.
It's like the absence of fear
is the best way I can put it.
Why are you so.
Were you so skeptical
that they would even find him gu
Because I know that you have sai
that he has never faced
any consequences for his actions
his entire life.
Yeah.
He has been able to
get away with everything I mean,
you know,
I wasn't even able
to get a restraining order again
You know,
and I mean, just simple, simple
He was given 50% custody,
which had he been acquitted.
He could have showed up here in
and just taken my kids,
you know, and it seemed to be
it seemed to me
he seemed all powerful
that there was nothing I could e
You know,
even when we finally did get out
I mean, the police told me to go
home to him, you know,
sent me back home to my husband.
It just seemed
it seemed impossible that he cou
And no, I saw the evidence again
I knew logically
it was a pretty good case.
But emotionally, I just
he just seemed unbeatable.
But that's not the case.
And know
the two of you have six children
when you talk about your concern
about what that would look like.
One thing that you said
that stood out to me
after the verdict came down
is that you were concerned
he might try to seek a pardon
if Trump is reelected.
I mean, that's
the shadow over all of this.
I know that that's
what he's mentally doing
right now as he is regrouping.
And I'm not even sure
it would have to be Trump.
I think maybe a potential DeSant
presidency.
There's still the potential
for a pardon there.
I know it's light.
I know that Trump could have par
before, you know, and he didn't.
So but there's that slight shado
you know?
I know that
that is what Stuart's doing righ
He's already
mentally he's already on the nex
You know, the power that he has
others, right?
The power to persuade, the power
to inspire, the power to compel
Do you believe that this convict
on such a charge that is such a
or two
to reach conviction on will dete
some of those followers who
I think some
my fear is that
these criminal charges,
it's hard to imagine,
but they don't really hurt him
on the extreme right.
And it's one of the reasons
I feel sometimes
compelled to just talk
about the more personal side of
The the the abuse the
the misusing of funds of Cuba
so it doesn't get talked about a
because a lot of people look at
like, well,
you misuse funds,
but it's extremist money. So wha
But it does hurt him on the righ
and that does
keep him from potentially rising
in a in an appeal scenario
or a pardons in those cases.
So I think that's one of the rea
I feel like I need to talk about
the more personal side of him an
and all the damage
he's caused to everyone, you kno
not just criminally.
Tasha, do you feel safe
I said I should have asked you
because you talked
about your kids and you.
Do you feel safe now?
I do.
I mean, of course, there's some
with some of his followers.
I do get messages.
You know, I did get some last ni
I've dishonored my husband.
This is all my fault.
I mean, I'm
pretty used to everything being
so that didn't faze me too much.
The FBI has been great.
They check in on me,
ask me, double check.
You know, is there anything you'
you know, even getting bad messa
Hmm.
Good.
And it's really the first time
I've been able to breathe easy a
maybe decades Say the truth.
Wow. Tasha, thank you.
We're glad that you're safe.
And thank you so much for appear
Thank you.